[Música]
bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de medio
ambiente seguimos produciendo el
programa cada semana desde casa como
medida de prevención por la situación de
la pandemia de kobe 19 en bogotá donde
están las oficinas de france 24 en
español dos días antes de la cumbre
sobre biodiversidad de la onu 64 países
de los cinco continentes además del
gobierno de la unión europea firmaron el
compromiso de líderes por la naturaleza
un documento con diez puntos en los que
los gobiernos de estas naciones
pretenden aumentar la ambición mundial
en cuanto a las acciones tomadas para
proteger a nuestro planeta y a las
personas durante la próxima década uno
de los puntos más interesantes y el
primero en la lista es en el que se
comprometen a situar a la biodiversidad
el clima y el medio ambiente en el
centro de sus estrategias y planes de
reactivación y recuperación económica
tras la pandemia de kobe 19 además hacen
patente su compromiso de incluir de
manera plena y efectiva a los pueblos
indígenas y comunidades locales
de decisiones además de incorporar el
concepto de una sola salud un concepto
que se refiere a la relación y unión
indiscutible entre la salud humana y la
sostenibilidad ambiental el documento
finaliza haciendo un llamado a la
importancia de basar estas decisiones en
la ciencia y en el conocimiento de
pueblos originarios y se compromete a
responder no sólo con palabras sino con
acciones y rendición de cuentas para
solucionar la emergencia planetaria
cinco de las diez mayores economías del
mundo respaldaron el compromiso sin
embargo el primer ministro canadiense
justin crudo recordó que canadá es el
único de los diez países geográficamente
más grandes del mundo que se ha
comprometido a reducir la pérdida de
biodiversidad
un niño indirecto a china y estados
unidos los dos países más contaminantes
del planeta que no forman parte de este
documento del que tampoco es partícipe
brasil junto con canadá y la unión
europea reino unido se comprometió
también a proteger el 30 por ciento de
tierras y océanos antes del año 2030
una estrategia que según un informe
publicado en julio tendría beneficios
económicos cinco veces mayores de los
recursos que se necesitarían invertir
para conseguirlo además como próximo
país anfitrión de la cumbre sobre cambio
climático de la onu que se celebra en
noviembre del año que viene aseguró que
no nos podemos permitir retrasar más el
momento de actuar
en resumen necesitamos no sólo buenas
intenciones sino acciones reales y
debemos actuar ahora ahora mismo no
podemos permitirnos tener dudas o
demoras porque la pérdida de
biodiversidad está sucediendo hoy en día
a una velocidad alarmante
y si no la controlamos las consecuencias
serán catastróficas para todos nosotros
cuando una especie desaparece desaparece
para siempre la extinción es permanente
así que nuestras acciones deben ser
inmediatas güisqui
españa también forma parte de los países
que se adhirieron a este compromiso
mientras que 8 países en latinoamérica
lo respaldaron bolivia colombia costa
rica guatemala honduras méxico panamá
paraguay y perú
cambiamos de tema cuando hablamos o
pensamos en contaminación
automáticamente nos imaginamos escenas
de plástico en el mar de basura o de los
cielos contaminados sin embargo hay un
tipo de polución menos explícita pero
que está presente en casi todos los
lugares nos referimos a la contaminación
lumínica este problema preocupa cada vez
más a chile' país líder en astronomía y
que depende de sus cielos oscuros para
poder seguir siéndolo por eso defensores
de la oscuridad están comenzando a
interponer demandas contra grandes
empresas que se saltan las regulaciones
impuestas e interfieren con la pureza
del cielo sobre todo en la región del
desierto de atacama al norte del país
que está viendo una explosión en la
cantidad de ciudades centros comerciales
y autopistas tras el auge del sector de
la minería de cobre y litio un aumento
en industria y población que viene de la
mano con un aumento en la contaminación
lumínica que además de afectar a los
paisajes flora fauna y salud de la
población de la región pone en peligro
la competitividad de chile en el sector
científico ya tenemos experiencia
durante el siglo pasado
en lugares como el sur de california
donde estaban los observatorios más
grandes del mundo donde se hicieron los
descubrimientos científicos más
importantes del siglo 20 en los cuales
el crecimiento descontrolado de la
contaminación lumínica terminó volviendo
son lugares completamente irrelevantes
científicamente en el sentido de que
perdieron su competitividad y los
siguientes proyectos grandes se fueron
yendo a otros lugares como al norte de
chile- en los chilenos tenemos un
patrimonio natural que es este
laboratorio natural del desierto atacama
que es único en el mundo y tiene un
valor enorme en lugar desde donde la
humanidad estudia el universo estudio el
cosmos y trata de entender los orígenes
de la vida de los elementos químicos de
los planetas de la galaxia etcétera
y como chilenos tenemos un deber muy
fuerte de cuidar este patrimonio que
tenemos en el país pero chile no es el
único país afectado por supuesto así que
si quieren seguir viendo las estrellas
desde su casa estén en la ciudad o estén
en el campo estas son algunas de las
cosas que pueden hacer apagar las luces
cuando no las estén utilizando algo que
además
a su factura y sus emisiones de gases de
efecto invernadero también pueden
mantener la luz interior dentro de las
casas
cerrando cortinas o persianas cuando sea
de noche colocar sensores de movimiento
en las luces exteriores para que solo se
activen cuando usted las necesite y
siempre instalar lámparas de exterior
con pantallas que dirijan la luz hacia
abajo con imágenes de los increíbles y
los chilenos me despido sigan con más
medio ambiente en france 24 punto com
[Música]
e